sen bana ne yazdım bağırdım bana ne bu
hamdan kardan bana ne yazsam bahardım
malibu aldım kardan aşağıdan yukarıdan
yolun sonu görünüyor aşağıdan yukarıdan
yolun sonu görünüyor geçtim dünya
üzerinden kömür bilmem ne fıstık bak
beni
sağ ol canım benim de yolun sonu
görünüyor bu dünyanın direği yok
merhameti neren yok bu dünyanın direği
yok merhameti nereye yok kuzum gereği
yolun sonu görünüyor kılavuzu yolun sonu
görünüyor
bu azrailim gelir kendi ne ağa der ne
efendi sıralı günler tükendi yolun sonu
görünüyor geçtim dünya üzerinden ömür
bir nefeste yerinde bakıyım çemberinden
yolun sonu görünüyor yok mu
abone ol
o çok teşekkürler hepinize tekrar
görüşmek dileğiyle hoşçakalın
[Alkış]